Musik
Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Da sind wir schon wieder. Du bist wahnsinnig leise, kannst du bitte ein bisschen lauter sprechen? Und da sind wir schon wieder. Ein bisschen leiser. Und da sind wir schon wieder. Lernt man das eigentlich auch im Sprechtraining, so seine Lautstärke perfekt zu kontrollieren, dass man das dann genau abstimmen kann? Ja, wenn man so will. Also könntest du genaue Dezibelgrenzen treffen? Ja, also wenn du mir sagst, ich muss genau jetzt minus zwei Dezibel treffen, könnte ich das schaffen. Das heißt, Stefan Titzel aus Bernbach wettet, dass er es schafft, vorgegebene von Lionel Richie vorgegebene Dezibelzahlen perfekt zu treffen. Sehe ich das richtig? Ja, richtig. Gut, wir geben mal ganz kurz zurück an die Couch, was sagt Lionel Richie? Vier, zeigt er mit den Fingern, vier Dezibel. Okay, dann ab jetzt bitte einmal einen Song von Lionel Richie. Als kleinen, nicht wahr, da lacht er, da muss er auch selber ein bisschen lachen. Einfach mal einen Song von Lionel Richie mit genau vier Dezibel. Top, die Wette gilt. Vier ist sehr laut, ne? Ganz kurz eine Nachfrage. Da kann ich Ihnen jetzt nicht weiterhelfen, Herr Titzer. Sie haben die Wette eingereicht. Vielleicht können wir das Publikum kurz mal Daumen hoch runter zeigen. Okay. Say you, say me! Ich glaube, das waren... Waren das... Schauen wir mal nach. Das waren 13 Dezibel. Okay. Schade. Naja, schön, dass Sie da gewesen sind.
Vielen Dank trotzdem.
Und genau, wir kommen jetzt zu unserem nächsten Act, Musik-Act, das heißt, Sie können schon mal wegschalten. Das wäre doch mal ein Gag, oder? Wenn jemand mal so einen Gag machen würde, dann wetten das. Das wäre doch mal was, da würde ich sagen, hallo, ist das eine gute Show, Mensch. Und unser nächster Kandidat, Florentin Will, er wettet, dass er zehn Gegenstände anhand des Geräusches erkennen kann. Gegenstand eins. Ich dachte, ich komme auf die Couch, weil ich war ja schon im Fernsehen und ich dachte eigentlich, dass ich für die Couch eingeladen war. Achtung, Gegenstand eins. Wie, ich soll jetzt eine Wette machen? Eine Schere. Nein. Ein Kugelschreiber? Ja. Sehr gut. Okay. Sehr gut. Du hast wieder gewonnen. Kann ich mich trotzdem noch auf die Gaufe setzen? Nee, das kleine Richie darfst du jetzt ins Phantasialand. Oh, wow, geil! Das war der Preis. Dankeschön. Ich finde es auch immer komisch, dass die Kinderwetten, die wurden immer so gut prämiert und dann wurde immer genau auf das jeweilige Kind ein Preis geschnitzt und die ganzen anderen Erwachsenen, die haben dann vielleicht entweder gar nichts bekommen oder halt so ein Auto und ein bisschen Geld. So, aber auch erst, wenn was gewählt wurde, wobei die Kinderwetten ja meist die wesentlich unspannenderen waren. Ich kannte tatsächlich mal jemanden, der eine Kinderwette gewonnen hat. Echt? Aber ich finde daran, dass letztlich auch das kaputt gegangen ist., glaube ich. Aber wen kattest du denn? Was hat der gemacht? Der war in meinem Schachclub, tatsächlich. Das ist auch ein guter Satz, ein guter erster Satz fürs Date. Bist du, erster Date? Ich kenne da jemanden, der war in meinem Schachclub. Und tschüss, ich bin, sorry, sorry, oh, er hat noch zu Hause was auf dem Herd, Entschuldigung. Ja, die Frau ist schon total gehypt. Was, du kennst jemanden, der meine Kinderwette gewonnen hat? Geil, er hat die Hose schon halb offen und dann Schachglocken. Nein, blöd. Also die Frau ärgert sich ja auch selber, dass man nicht in die richtige Richtung gehen kann. Nee, und er hat gewettet, dass er es schaffen kann und ich erinnere mich noch, das habe ich schon mal erklärt, das kommt mir sehr bekannt vor, aber vielleicht habe ich es auch einfach erlebt. Ich tue es mittlerweile auch so, als habe ich die Geschichte noch nie gehört habe. Ja, was aber tatsächlich mich in meiner Psychose noch viel weiter vertieft, dass ich immer das Gefühl habe, Dinge schon mal gesagt zu haben. Ich hatte tatsächlich, wir hatten kurz vor der Sendung geredet, ob wir nochmal den ersten Menschen machen sollen. Und ich glaube, ich habe drei Dinge geschrieben, die wir alle schon mal gebracht haben, die Gags. Deswegen habe ich diese Rubrik für tot erklärt. Ne, mal, kommen wir vielleicht später nochmal dazu. Aber auf jeden Fall hat er gewettet, dass er es schaffen kann. Du bist so ein Baum, bist du gerade, der in so ganz viel Richtung abzweigt, aber dann doch noch den Weg findet, den er eigentlich gehen will. Sehr gut, Sommerreferenz. In die Richtung Sonne, in Richtung Sommer, unser heutiges Thema. Dankeschön. Und zwar hat er gewettet, dass er es schaffen kann von einem gewissen Schachbrett, also ein leeres Schachbrett. Und Stefan Raab gibt eine Position vor, also sagen wir jetzt mal B8, klassische Position. Krieg ich Stefan Raab jetzt? Herr Stefan Raab, das ist die Figur, die man immer nur eine Figur ziehen kann.
Oder halt alle sieben Züge darf man die einmal... B8, klassische Position. Will ich Stefan Raab jetzt? Stefan Raab, das ist die Figur, die man immer nur eine Figur ziehen kann.
Oder alle sieben Züge darf man die einmal führen. Die ist mittlerweile auch verboten worden, die wurde rausgepatcht, die war zu gut tatsächlich. Und auf jeden Fall hat Stefan Raab eine Position vorgegeben und auf diese Position wurde der Springer gesetzt, mit der Bild-Zeitung. Und ab dann musste der Typ den Springer immer führen, so dass er alle Felder auf dem Schachbrett einmal passiert hat, aber auch nur einmal. Da gibt es halt nur einen Weg, der wahrscheinlich geht. Es gibt nur einen Weg und die letzte Position hätte ihn tatsächlich auch wieder auf die erste gebracht. Das heißt, er merkt sich einfach eine Kette von Positionen und es ist völlig egal, auf welchen Platz man gesetzt wird, der rattert die einfach dann einmal so im Kreis runter. Und den habe ich mal gesehen in meinem Schachklub und dachte mir, krasser Typ. Aber interessant, also ich finde, man kann an den Leuten, die man im Freundeskreis hat, die mal bei Wetten, dass teilgenommen haben oder teilnehmen wollten, erkennt man ganz gut so die Peergroup, in der man war. Weil ich kenne mir jemanden, der hat sich da beworben, wurde aber glaube ich nie genommen oder war in einer engeren Auswahl, der konnte Fussballschuhe erkennen, also der aus 100 Fussballschulen konnte er am Geräusch der, wie sie atmen, manche Schuhe atmen, nein, er konnte die glaube ich einfach nicht etwas zu breite Fantasie. Er konnte am Hand des Etikettes erkennen, was es für ein Schuh ist. Aber der Trick war eigentlich, dass sein Fantasiefreund hatte ja die Augen offen und konnte ihm sagen, welche Schuhe es waren. Von daher war die Wette sehr einfach. Er konnte es anhand der Schilder, die davor stand, erkennen, was es für ein Schuh war. Ja, das war die Idee. Ich verstehe. Aber man sieht da natürlich wesentlich cooler die Aufnahmeart. Gesundheit! Ich habe gehustet. Ich wollte ganz kurz sagen, Garage Band, Garage Band, keine Ahnung, wie es ausspricht, die hatten jedenfalls waren kurz davor, Podcast-Ufo zu verhindern heute. Ich weiß nicht, ob das auch so gegangen ist, aber ich habe es geöffnet eben und dann kam erst mal diese These, vielen Dank, dass sie die neue Version runtergeladen haben. Genau, die gewagte These erstmal so. Nein, habe ich nicht. Habe ich nicht. Und dann stand da, ja, wir laden jetzt erstmal alle Sounds runter und ja, das kann bis zu einer Stunde dauern. Stand da so, dachte mir, ja, dann findet das Podcast-Urfall auch nicht statt, das ist mir dann auch egal, aber das ist einfach zu lang. So lange will ich auch nicht darauf warten, aber da ging es relativ schnell. Eben, ich wollte gerade sagen, was ist denn das für ein geiles Gefühl, wenn da steht, bei einer
durchschnittlichen Breitbandverbindung kann das
bis zu einer Stunde dauern, verbleibend
drei Minuten. Und du denkst dir, Alter,
oder? Meine fucking Breitbandverbindung,
bumm, nicht
durchschnittlich. Das ist, glaube ich, auch so ein
Apple-Ding. Die wollen einfach so ein
gutes Gefühl einem umgeben mit allem.
Die untertreiben erst mal generell immer, ja, das kann ein dauern. Und dann dauert es halt eine Minute und du denkst dir so, hey, it's me. Das ist tatsächlich gut. Da kommen wir auch nochmal auf die deutsche Bahn zurück, vielleicht, wenn wir später nochmal die Kurve schlagen. Oh ja, da waren wir auch noch nie, glaube ich, oder? Aber auch mit so vorauseilendem Gehorsam. Ich habe auch so eine Spam-Mail bekommen von so einer Charity-Organisation. Ir, irgendwie Kinderkrebs, Hilfe oder irgendwie so Hilfe, mir fehlen beide Beine, ich bin ein Kind, Organisation, so eine Geschichte. Und dann wurde diese Spam-Mail beendet. So ein ganz trauriger Smiley als Logo. Ja, so ein Smiley, dem beide Beine fehlen, so ein bisschen, aber ja, der hat im Tischsitz vielleicht. Auf jeden Fall wurde diese Mail beendet mit den Worten, wir hoffen, dass sie uns auch in Zukunft weiter unterstützen. Und ich auch dachte so, nee, eigentlich finde ich ein bisschen frech, ehrlich gesagt, dass sie jetzt von weiter unterstützen. Ich habe diese Spam-Mail gelesen, das war die vollständige Unterstützung und ich werde sie auch löschen wahrscheinlich, tut mir leid. Naja, aber guck mal, ist da vielleicht eine Taktik dahinter, also wenn man einmal schon mal gespendet hat oder zumindest denkt, dass man es dann eher nochmal macht und dass sie deswegen an das Innerste des Menschen appellieren. Ich glaube, ich würde es fast anders machen, dass wenn ich sage, ich habe ja schon mal für euch gespendet, euch gibt es immer noch, aka, ihr habt es nicht geschafft, euren Charity-Effekt zu erfüllen. Das muss ich auch sagen, die Existenz einer Charity-Organisation zeigt, dass sie nicht erfolgreich ist. Nein. Doch, wenn du den Welthunger beenden willst und du arbeitest bei der Welthungerhilfe und dann sagst du, ja, Kinder, eigentlich hätte ich gerne in zwei Jahren keinen Job mehr, weil irgendwann muss das auch gemacht werden. Es gibt im Weltall mehrere Welten und du weißt nicht, wie viele Welten die schon gerettet haben. N24 heisst jetzt die Welt. Ja, danke schön. Kleiner medienjournalistischer Einwurf kann kann ja auch mal sein tatsächlich. Aber ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich bei Charity-Organisationen ein echtes Problem, dass die Leute sich denken, hey, wenn wir jetzt wirklich alle Probleme lösen, haben wir keinen Job mehr. Ja. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass das ein echtes Problem ist. Meinst du das? Glaubst du, dass die am Meetingstisch sitzen und denken so, wir können die Welt jetzt nicht komplett heil machen, sonst gibt es uns nicht mehr? Ich glaube, Menschen arbeiten relativ ungern an ihrer eigenen Abschaffung. Generell ist jetzt so eine Vermutung. Aber ist es nicht so, als würden Musiker keine Musik mehr machen, damit die Nachfrage von Musik noch da ist? Ist es etwa das Gleiche? Ist es nicht vergleichbar? Dass sie einfach nicht arbeiten, bis die Leute so dringend Musik wollen,
dass sie mehr dafür zahlen.
Aber man kriegt es wahrscheinlich nicht koordiniert.
Es gibt dann immer irgendwie Taylor Swift oder so, die so lange
nicht arbeiten,
bis der Wert halt scheisse geht und man
Charity-Aktionen braucht.
Das finde ich ganz gut, dass es so einen Tag in der Woche
keinen Käse gibt, aber am nächsten Tag ist der Käse
doppelt so teuer. Vielleicht.
Ich glaube, da würden die richtig viel Geld verdienen. Oder noch einen Tag warten, bis er wieder billiger ist, man weiß will, aus einer objektiven Vogelperspektive miterleben, was ganz schön war. Also wie man halt so montags sitzt man dann zusammen in einem grossen Meeting und dann wird um 10 Uhr auch Florentin erwartet. Weil er ist nicht jede Woche da, er ist auch nicht jeden Tag, er ist nur montags da manchmal. Und gestern war eben so ein Tag, ein berüchteter Florentin-Will-Tag, wie ich ihn dann immer nenne, und dick ankreuze beim Kalender. Und dann hieß es, um zehn Uhr ist er da. Dann kam schon so um kurz vor zehn die Meldung. Du musst ganz kurz sagen, also das Meeting fand in Köln statt, und ich wohne ja in Berlin, das heißt, ich musste vor zehn eine viereinhalbstündige Zugfahrt nach Köln abliefern. Du bist irgendwann so irgendwie um zwei Uhr nachts losgefahren, aufgestanden, irgendwie so um den Dreh, kann man sich vorstellen, und dann kam schon um kurz vor zehn, also vorhin sind schon seit zwölf Stunden gefühlt im Zug, kommt dann so eine Meldung, ja ganz kurz, ich werde mich womöglich massiv verspäten. Schon ein Lacher am Morgen, schon ein Lacher am Morgen, dachte ich mir, okay, ist nicht schlimm, ich bin auch zu spät, passt schon. Dann um 11 Uhr, wo man hätte sagen können, alle warten schon so lange auf Florentin, dann kam dann die Meldung, ja, ich bin jetzt hier gerade irgendwo, weiß ich gar nicht wo, weil es hier keine Schilder gibt und mein ICE ist leer. Also irgendwie dachte ich mir, gut, du bist halt so eine tragische Persönlichkeit, womit du bist eigentlich einfach falsch abgebogen und irgendwie falsch umgestiegen und bist einfach in einem leeren ICE, der irgendwie an einem Abstellgleis gereinigt wird oder so. Auf plötzlich komische Umstände bist du da hingeraten. Ja, und dann hieß es irgendwann, ja gut, ich wohin, die brauchen eigentlich gar nicht mehr kommen. Und dann durfte ich die lustige SMS schreiben, dass du gar nicht mehr kommen musstest. Mit dem Wissen, dass du schon zwölf Stunden unterwegs bist und wieder den gleichen Weg zurück kannst, ohne den ganzen Tag was erreicht zu haben. Ja, was ich mir auch gedacht habe, ist das eigentlich dann cool, noch jemandem zu sagen, so nee, du musst gar nicht mehr kommen, heisst, okay, ich stelle jetzt mit dieser Nachricht fest, dass du den gesamten Tag durch Deutschland gefahren bist, ohne Sinn. Ja, vor allem auch, wenn man dir sagt, du musst nicht mehr kommen. Sinnlos ist eine Erklärung. Also man kann natürlich sagen, du musst nicht mehr kommen, ist nett gemeint, wir wollen dir Arbeit ersparen. Das kann aber auch heißen wie, ja, uns ist gerade um elf Uhr aufgefallen, dass wir auch eine Stunde gut ohne dich nachgekommen sind. Ja, vor allem wir machen dadurch deinen gesamten Tag sinnlos. Ja, genau. Weißt du, wenn du halt kommen würdest und dann wenigstens zehn Minuten mit uns reden würdest und dann wieder fährst und sagst, okay, gut, ja. Aber war der ganze Tag für dich sinnlos oder hast du irgendwas geschafft? Also es war so, es war so tatsächlich der Zug. Also ich fange mal ganz vorne an. Ich bin ja ein humoristischer Typ, ja, deswegen überlege ich mir immer, was ist der erste Gag, den ich an einem Tag höre? Ich wache auf und denke mir, okay, Welt, zeig mir, was du drauf hast, zeig mir, was du zu bieten hast, was kommt heute? Und ich aktiv überlege, was wird wohl der erste Witt sein? Meistens ist es irgendwas, wenn ich frühstücke und auf Twitter oder so rumlese oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Aber an dem Tag, an dem ich mir so früh aufstehe, mache ich das nicht, weil ich sofort los muss. Deswegen dachte ich mir, was könnte der erste Gag sein, der heute noch passiert.
Der ist ja auch so ein bisschen sinnstiftend für den Rest des Tages, der ist ja so die Overtüre, er setzt die Stimmung an, was noch kommen kann. Man fühlt sich auch anders, je nachdem wie viele und welche guten Gags man hört so am Tag. Und dann komme ich also an am Bahnsteig und sehe schon, oh, zehn Minuten Verspätung, uiuiuiui, okay, die Gagkanone wird langsam geladen, der Revolver wird aufgemacht, die erste Patrone geht rein. Okay, 20 Minuten Verspätung, nochmal, man kramt in seinem Munitionsgürtel die Leute um mich rum, man guckt schon sich so ein bisschen an, hat jemand was auf der Zunge, die zweite Kugel wird geladen, noch passiert nichts. Dann 30 Minuten Verspätung, man schaut sich ein bisschen beschämt an, irgendwas, irgendwann muss die Bomme platzen und plötzlich hört man von Gleis D-Abschnitt jemanden ironisch applaudierend. Und das sollte er gewesen sein, der erste Gag des Tages, des Montags, ironischer Applaus auf dem Bahnsteig in Berlin. Und ich dachte mir schon, wow, wenn das der erste Gag des Tages ist, dann wird es hart. Aber ich habe die Person wirklich gefeiert, wo man sagen muss, er hat es tatsächlich der Gruppe ermöglicht, das nochmal in ironischem Spektrum zu schauen. Er hat der ganzen Gruppe geholfen und da sagt man immer, ja, Comedians braucht kein Mensch, wer hat Arzt, wer hat Anwalt, das brauchen die Leute. Nee, Comedian ist es, der tatsächlich um vier Uhr morgens es schafft, auf dem Bahnsteig der ganzen Gruppe ein gutes Gefühl zu geben. Auf jeden Fall, nochmal zurück. Ja, gutes Gefühl, aber ironisches Klatschen ist ja jetzt nicht irgendwie, also es gibt immer keine. Es waren Lacher, es waren Schmunzler. Hat der ganze Bahnsteig von A bis Z, keine Ahnung, wie weit es geht, aber haben die alle gelacht, haben die alle da gelegen, auf dem Boden gelegen, auf dem Gleis gelegen. Hahaha, sind vom Bahnsteig gefallen. Das wäre echt saulustig, wenn man wirklich irgendwas macht und alle lachen schallend. Da man, also das ist wirklich eine interessante Humorfrage, ob es einen Gag gäbe, der es schafft, eine so bunt gemischte Gruppe, da waren Studenten, Kinder, Erwachsene, Alte Leute, alle möglichen Leute, ob es wirklich einen Gag geben könnte, der alle Menschen zum Lachen bringt.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Es gibt ja diesen Monty-Python-Gag-Sketch, in dem es den besten Witz der Welt gibt, wo alle Leute von sterben, weil die so lachen müssen. Das ist ja in etwa das Gleiche. Und das ist auch eine gute Frage. Wie nehmen wir da die Wissenschaft vom Lachen, Geleontologie oder so? Luke Mockridge. Müssen wir mal einen Gelontologen fragen, einen berühmten,
aber es ist generell mal ein guter Gast für uns.
Ein berühmter Lachwissenschaftler,
Humorwissenschaftler, auf jeden Fall.
Können wir mal einladen in den Podcast, oder? Jetzt mal ohne Scheiß.
Das ist tatsächlich ein guter Punkt, muss ich mir
aufschreiben, Gäste, Humorwissenschaftler.
Warum machen wir das denn nicht? Leider reißt die Internetverbindung
gerade etwas ab. Wir laden den einfach jetzt ein.
Vielleicht hören wir auch jetzt gleich von Stefan Tizzi ironisches Klatschen über seine Breitbandverbindung. Mal gucken, ob er diesen Gag verwandelt oder nicht. Leute, wenn das der erste Gag eures Tages ist, dann wird das ein beschissener Tag. Also müsst ihr euch schon klar sein. Ihr müsst jetzt schon da ein bisschen was vorweg geliefert haben. Ja, okay, dann hau rein mit deinem Gelontologen. Gelontologie heißt es nämlich, und der heißt, also ich habe, ohn Scheisse, ich habe von Wikipedia Gelontologie,
quasi die Wissenschaft der Auswirkungen des Lachens und den psychischen Aspekten des Lachens,
habe ich aufgerufen, und der erste Experte, der genannt wurde, heißt wie?
Michael Tietze.
Nein, das kann nicht sein.
Der heißt genau wie ich und wird auch genau so geschrieben.
Vor heißt wie? Michael Tietze. Nein, das kann nicht sein. Er wird auch genauso geschrieben.
Vorläufige Forschungsergebnisse.
Alter, wie gut ist das denn?
Therapeutischer Humor und Gelut.
Alter, schau dir mal die Website an.
Das ist total gut.
Michael-Tietze.de
Echt jetzt?
Das Lustige ist, ich habe einen zweiten Namen.
Und wie habe ich einen zweiten Namen?
Richtig, Franz. Ich heiße Michael mit dem zweiten Namen. Alter, jetzt wird es aber echt gruselig. Humorkongress. Humorkongress 2015 in Basel am 26. September. Da fahren wir aber hin, ohne Witz. Ja, aber wie wir da sind, natürlich sind wir da. Wir fahren nach Basel zum zweiten Humorkongress. Ja, gern. Fucking, ohne Witz, ey, wir müssen uns da irgendwie so einen Stand holen. Und wir machen ein Hörertreffen. Die ganzen Podcast-Ufo-Hörer sollen nach Basel. Fucking 2015. So Doktor Michael Tietze. Ich bin vielleicht verwandt mit dem. Wie gut ist das denn? Ich bin vielleicht verwandt mit ihm. Humorkongress.ch Aber wie cool wäre das denn, wenn die Tietze so ein Clan ist, der sich seit Jahren mit Humor und Lachen beschäftigt, irgendwie so im Untergrund spinnen die die Fäden in der Humorindustrie. Ist das gut? Die Humorkongress Basel hat auch eine Facebook-Seite, du musst dir das mal anschauen, das sind nur alte Leute, das ist ja grossartig. Das ist ja fantastisch. Um Gottes Willen ist das unglaublich. Ein wunderbar heiteres Wochenende, das ich letztes Jahr in Basel verbracht habe. Mit einer Prise Humor wird das Leben einfach leichter. Ja, mehr als eine Prise Humor kann man sich schon versprechen, als beim Humorkongress oder nicht. Ich glaube, der Humorkongress ist entweder die lustigste Veranstaltung der Welt oder die uncoolste Veranstaltung der Welt. Ich will den ganzen Beutelhumor, wenn ich auf den Humorkongress gehe. Nee, aber Humor, Kraftquelle des Lebens ist auch... Das ist ja grossartig. Kraftquelle des Lebens ist der Titel für den diesjährigen Humorkongress. Geil. Ist unglaublich. Ich habe die Seite sofort geleitet, wir werden da auf jeden Fall hingehen. Ja, da fahren wir hin. 26. September, Leute, streicht es euch jetzt schon mal gross im Kalender an, 26. September 2015 in Basel. Das ist ja unglaublich. In Basel treffen wir uns zum grossen Hörertreffen und da können wir mal endlich, vielleicht können wir mal Fachmännern auch irgendwie so eine CD von uns in die Hand geben und die sollen mal sagen, wo hapert es noch und was klappt schon vielleicht ganz gut und so aus Humor wissenschaftlicher Erste. Wir machen da Interviews, wir interviewen die Leute. Aber ganz ernst. Ich glaube, das wird eine ganz ernste Veranstaltung. Es hat mal irgendwer gesagt, war das nicht, wo die Ellen, irgendwer hat gesagt mal, wie man über Witz redet, ist das wie, wenn man einen Frosch seziert, man findet viel heraus, aber dabei stirbt der Frosch. Der Frosch ist tot. Ja, aber das ist ganz interessant. Ich glaube, es ist nämlich genau so eine Veranstaltung, wo einfach tausend tote Frösche rumliegen. Und die meisten Leute sehen auch einfach aus wie tote Frösche. Oi! Sehr geil. Finde ich richtig gut. Das ist echt gut. Hält der Michael Tietz eigentlich auch eine Vorlesung da irgendwie? Das würde mich schon mal interessieren. Ich habe hier nur Enrico Luisoni, der um 20.15 Uhr, am 26. September, die Anleitung zum lustvollen Leben. Kung-Fu mit Professor Bernhard Ludwig Seminarkabarett. Was? Zu Kung-Fu gibt es sicherlich genug Gelegenheit. Hallo, was ist denn das? Der Kung-Fu-Professor Bernhard Ludwig. Wie geil ist das denn? Aussteller. Auf jeden Fall gehen wir da hin. Wir stellen da auch aus, auf jeden Fall. Wir designen da Humorkongress drei Fachbeiträge von Michael Thietze ansehen und bestellen. Ey, warte, wir schreiben da heute noch eine Nachricht hin, dass wir da gerne auch auftreten wollen, dass wir glauben, dass wir sehr viel Humor haben und glauben, dass wir die Leute da zum Lachen bringen können. Und dann stellen wir ein Programm zusammen. Auf jeden Fall, das machen wir, das wird grossartig. Ja, auf jeden Fall, freue mich auch drauf. Leute, ihr kommt zahlreich, wenn wir den Humorkongress Basel mal ein bisschen mit einer Prise Humor... Ich finde, Basel ist auch die Comedy-Stadt, oder? Ist auch die Comedy-Stadt Europos. Ja, die Humor-Hochburg, auf jeden Fall. Achteinhalb Stunden Autofahrt, ach du Scheiße, naja gut, was soll's. Noch einen Roadtrip dahin. Das heißt, Leute, ohne Witz, jetzt heißt es nochmal den Flatterbutton streicheln. Wir brauchen Geld, wir brauchen Geld, um nach Basel zu kommen. Es wird wahrscheinlich einiges kosten, daran teilzunehmen, die Fahrt, wir brauchen Geld. Wir kaufen uns eine GoPro, hängen die ins Auto und machen einen Roadtrip. Nee, wir stecken die Florentin in seine Locken. Das liegt jetzt an euch. Ja, sehr gut. Das liegt jetzt an euch, wie ausgiebig wir diese Reise dokumentieren können. Vielleicht fahren wir hin und reden mit zwei Leuten und gehen dann einfach wieder. Oder der Zug kommt zu spät und wir fahren einfach durch. Wir können einfach einen ganzen 90-Minüter drehen. Ja, wir können fucking Spielfilm drehen. Ja, klar. Unser Humorkongress Basis. Das liegt jetzt nur an euch. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das liegt an euch. Geht auf podcast-ufo.fail und drückt diesen fucking Flatter-Button, bis er aus der Tastatur fällt. Ich sag mal so, 90 Minuten kostet schon so ein paar Millionen, müsste das schon... Och Mensch, auch in Deutschland, das ist alles nicht so... Du in Basel, die haben wirklich sehr geringe Grenzkosten, glaube ich. Ich hab gerade eben beim Reden darüber nachgedacht, vielleicht gibt's beim Humor, ist es vielleicht wie bei Star Wars mit diesem Midi-Chlorianer-Wert, quasi wenn das, also man kann das messen im Blut.
Ja genau, vielleicht hat jeder so eine gewisse Anzahl kleiner Tierchen, die in einem leben, die so Humortierchen, Tietzchen und die sorgen halt dafür, dass man Humor hat und Humor von sich gibt und vielleicht kann man das messen mit so Blutproben, das wäre mir interessant.
Das sind so Fragen, die kann man den Leuten dann mal stellen, die bewegen mich, die bewegen dich, das weiß ich. Dann können wir den Leuten dann die Fragen stellen und dann haben wir endlich mal Antworten auf die Fragen, die wir stellen. Patrick Hofer, der Regisseur, Bratschist, Komödiant, Impro-Spieler, Clown und Coach. Bratschist, Komödiant und Impro-Spieler. Aber ohne Scheiss, Abendprogramm Kung-Fu. Ich finde, überall wo das Abendprogramm Kung-Fu ist, ist man richtig. Ich fühle mich richtig. Das beste Abendprogramm ever. Grossartig, jetzt nimmt sich hier noch einen Donut und ein Ab zum Kung-Fu. Sponsoren, auch interessant. Die Sponsoren des Humorkongresses Basel 2015 sind Alzheimer-Vereinigung Basel, Gesundheitsdienste Basel und Humor.ch Humor.ch Grossartig. Wir werden euch auf dem Laufenden halten. Wir werden auf jeden Fall hinschreiben und unsere Korrespondenz werden wir offenlegen, das ist ein transparenter Podcast und ihr verdient, ihr seid jetzt auch Teil dieses Events, das wir am 26. September in Basel feiern werden. Basel hört man ja, ist eine fantastische Stadt. Ich finde auch, der 26. Wow, wow, ich freue mich. Der 26. soll auch für uns dann irgendwie jährlich so ein Tag sein, an dem man irgendwie den Humor feiert. Der Humortag, ja. Es sollte unser persönlicher Tag sein, unser persönlicher Feiertag sein, den wir in Deutschland dann irgendwie auch durchsetzen. Vielleicht können wir auch es schaffen, das könnte auch so ein Ziel des Tages sein dann irgendwie, den Humorkongress 2016 nach Deutschland holen. Das wäre so ein Ziel, dass man das Event Humorkongress auch mal nach Deutschland bekäme. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht kriegen wir auch politische Unterstützung, ich weiß nicht, wer da Connections hat von euch. Mal gucken, also ich denke, wir könnten das riesig aufziehen. Um uns das Thema ganz kurz abzuschliessen, um mal zu zeigen, von welchem Kaliber wir hier überhaupt reden, ein Post des Humorkongress Basel zeigt ein Funny-Pick, ein lustiges Foto, und zwar ist dort ein gelber Briefkasten abgebildet und auf der Klappe, die den Schlitz verschliesst von dem Briefkasten, steht, bitte keine E-Mails. Wow. Hallöchen. Das hat mich jetzt auf allen Ebenen, den hat er mir das im Teppich unter den Füssen weggezogen, humortechnisch. Wow, ich freue mich darauf, das wird grossartig. Geil. Das wird grossartig dann. Grossartig. Toll. Mein Gott. Um da ganz kurz nochmal meine Anekdote zu Ende zu bringen, warum ich finde, dass die Bahn Feelgood-Bahn genannt werden sollte. Und zwar haben die folgenden Trick angewendet. Der Zug hat sich, nachdem er schon 30 Minuten verspätet war, letztlich glaube ich eineinhalb Stunden verschoben oder sowas. Aber, was ich sehr geil fand, also die Stimmung wurde immer schlechter, immer weiter dem Tiefpunkt zu. Die Leute haben sich Süssigkeiten gekauft, um sich noch halbwillig irgendwie ein Endorphin-Level aufrechtzuerhalten. Und dann wurde es immer schlimmer, 45 Minuten, 50 Minuten, 60 Minuten, immer schlimmer. Aber, kurz bevor der Zug kam, wurde die Verspätung nochmal zurückgestuft. Das heißt, wir hatten irgendwann 90 Minuten und dann 85 Minuten Minuten und alle schon so Ding, Durchsage, oh Gott, fucking und dann fünfundachtzig und alle so, geil, okay, jetzt kommt er gleich und er kam direkt, was rückgewirkt und extrem klug ist, weil die Leute haben zwanzig Nachrichten bekommen, von denen neunzehn scheisse ist, aber solange die letzte gut ist, gehen die mit einem guten Gefühl ins Zug, weil sie denken, okay, geil, fünf Minuten kürzer warten, geil, er ist endlich da, zack, und schon hat die Bahn es geschafft, mit so einem billigen Psychotrick die Leute gut darauf einzustimmen, dass sie gar nicht mehr so schlecht draus sind. Finde ich auch, gute Idee. Viel gut, viel gut, Bahn passt dann ganz gut. Aber ich finde auch, dass öffentliches Aufregen auch so ein Ding ist, was glaube ich die Deutschen auch perfektioniert haben auf eine Art, weil ich war gestern, es war ja wirklich auch sehr warm hier in Köln, war es auch sehr warm und da verstehe ich schon mal, wenn die U-Bahnen hier auch mal Probleme haben und dann stehen bleiben, aber ich persönlich habe da Verständnis für und dann fuhren wir gerade in die Station ein und dann gehen die Türen auf, alle gehen raus und dann sah man plötzlich, wie der Lokführer, U-Bahn-Fahrer halt aussteigt und zusammen Telefon geht und die ganze Bahn hat schon schon so unisono gestöhnt. Nein, weil man den Glockführer schon rausgehen sieht und so ein Telefon greifen sieht, ist halt nie gut. Ja, und dann habe ich vor mir, ich sass rückwärts, in Fahrtrichtung rückwärts, und dann sass vor mir halt so eine ältere betagte Dame, die sich dann so öffentlich aufgeregt hat, groß gemacht hat, oh, scheiße hier schon wieder. Und dann kam Durchsage, ein bisschen Verspätung, aber versucht, das in den Griff zu bekommen. Er ging wieder zum Telefon und kam dann wieder dieser Durchsageton. Und daraufhin hat die Frau schon wieder so die Hände vors Gesicht genommen, aber die Durchsage war dann, ja, es geht sofort weiter, Moment, wir haben ein ganzes Teil Probleme gehabt. Aber sie hatte schon die Hände vorm Gesicht, sie hatte schon die Hände aufregend vorm Gesicht, hat es dann aber so gedreht, dass sie die Brille vorm Gesicht genommen hat und die geputzt hat, sodass es aussah, als würde sie sich gar nicht aufregen. Also sie hat gemerkt, dass die Aufregergeste schon so weit fortgeschritten war, dass sie dann nicht mehr ohne weiteres rauskommen. Wenn sie es weggenommen hätte, in Erleichterung weggenommen hätte, wäre das einfach peinlich gewesen. Aber die Deutschen sind da so weit, sie haben schon die passenden Auswege. Ja, das ist unfassbar. Ja, das ist echt gut. Das ist echt schön. Das ist großartig. Ja, vor allem, ich kann echt nicht nachvollziehen, wie man sich da aufregen kann. Also wirklich. Weil es war dann tatsächlich so, am Tag davor war halt irgendwie krasses Gewitter die Nacht durch, weil es so heiß war dieses Wochenende. Und die hatten halt tatsächlich, ja, da lagen halt einfach fucking Bäume auf den Gleisen. Was sollen wir denn bitte machen? Sorry. Und dann kam noch eine Durchsage, ja, der Zug musste d vorne nochmal geprüft werden, weil es irgendwie technische Schwierigkeiten gab, irgendwie der musste nochmal abgecheckt werden, damit es passiert und die Strecke ist leider versperrt, wir müssen eine andere Spreche nehmen, die Leute, so eine Scheisse, die Scheissbahn wieder, wo ich mir dachte, was soll die denn machen, wenn da halt ein fucking Unwetter ist und da Bäume auf dem Gleis liegen, was sollen die denn machen, also wo ist der ein Fehler? Aber die Leute interessiert, das ist eine Scheisse.
Die denken keine zwei Sekunden nach, die einfach
aufregen, die freuen sich ja auch schon, den ganzen
Tag darauf sich aufzuregen und dann einfach zu sagen,
scheisse hier, da fahre ich sechsmal
mit dem Auto hier, ja gut, da liegt da halt
ein fucking Baum auf der Straße, was soll ich denn
dann machen, du Dödel? Ja, das stimmt,
aber ich glaube, da sind die Deutschen auch so weit,
man sagt ja immer die Deutschen, aber das ist glaube ich wirklich so.
Ja, man kommt auch gut an, mit Aufregung, Das ist das eigentliche Problem. Du merkst auf Twitter immer, zum Beispiel auf Twitter merkt man es ganz krass, sobald die Leute anfangen zu meckern, hagelt es Sterne aus allen Seiten. Und das ist tatsächlich echt ein Problem, sobald die sagen, oh, schon wieder Montag, oh, es ist heiß. Und dann vor allem kommt die Gegenfraktion, oh, die ganzen Leute, die schon wieder twittern, dass es so heiß ist, die kriegen auch wieder Sterne. Und dann, ganzen Leute, die schon wieder twittern, dass die Leute so viel twittern, dass es so heiß ist, die kriegen auch Sterne. Also das heißt, die Sterne widersprechen sich, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was sie tun, auch wenn sie sich die Leute über Aufregen aufregen. Die Leute lieben es, wenn sich Leute aufregen, völlig egal worüber. Es ist scheißegal worüber, es ist echt unfassbar. Und das ist ein Problem, dass es einfach so ein großes Becken gibt an Leuten, die einfach auf alles springen, was sich auf was aufregend und dann das einfach zu Tode liken. Und das ist echt ein Problem. Und ich rede mich jetzt auch gerade über das Aufregen auf, wo auch viele Leute jetzt wahrscheinlich gesagt haben, ja stimmt, es regen sich echt zu viele Leute auf, weil es halt einfach so ein scheiß... Und das ist auch falsch, Leute, die das gedacht haben. Es ist alles falsch, ihr macht alles falsch, ich auch, wir machen alles falsch, man kommt da nicht mehr gut raus aus der Situation, es funktioniert halt einfach nicht, es ist alles scheiße, das ist das Problem, belohnt Leute nicht, nein, einfach nicht liken, einfach nicht Sterne vergeben, wenn Leute sich aufregen, einfach gar keine Sterne geben, für gar nichts, für gar nichts Sterne geben. Nein, für lustige Sachen, für innovative und coole Ideen Sterne geben, aber nicht einfach für Sachen. Weil Twitter ist jetzt auch kein Comedy-Netzwerk. Ja, ich weiß schon, aber es ist ja trotzdem, ja okay, vielleicht heißt der Stern einfach bedeutend für reine Zustimmung. Von mir aus, wenn man sagt, es ist heiß draußen, ja, sehe ich genauso, Stern, okay, wenn Leute es so handhaben, gut. Aber für mich ist der Stern einfach noch so ein bisschen so, hey, cool, irgendwas Gutes dabei.
Mir hat mal jemand erklärt,
mir hat mal jemand erklärt, der jetzt mittlerweile mehr als 10.000 Twitter-Follower hat.
Das ist für mich so eine Marke, wo ich sage,
alles, was der mit über das Netzwerk sagt, ist für mich okay.
Der hat alles erreicht bei Twitter, alles, was er sagt, glaube ich ihm.
Und er hat gesagt, man soll sich so einen Follower wie ein Publikum vorstellen.
Also zum Beispiel, er hatte 10.000 Leute in der Halle, quasi die Lengsess Arena voll, ich habe jetzt 1.000 mittlerweile, also quasi die Turnhalle. Man soll sich die Leute halt vorstellen und die Sterne sind die Leute, die applaudieren nach einem Gag. Ja, so sehe ich das auch tatsächlich. Das ist eine lustige Vorstellung. Also alle Leute, die von deinen Followern einen Stern geben, würden in dem Fall applaudieren. Ja, aber stell dich mal auf die Bühne und sag, es ist draußen nachts dunkel. Die Leute werden nicht applaudieren, das ist keine einfache Zustimmung. Es sei denn, man regt sich darüber auf, was für eine Scheiße, dass es draußen schon wieder dunkel ist und die Leute rasten aus. Ja, das stimmt, das kenne ich. Die erste Reihe komplett... Ja, das ist... Das kenne ich, das ist bei mir auch so. Und dann klatschen die schon wieder.
Ich finde das aber die falsche Herangehensweise, weil die meisten Follower sind ja inaktiv.
Die anderen sind ja auch im Klo oder so.
Und nur ein gewisser Bruchteil hört ja überhaupt zu.
Das ist ja gerade bei Twitter und ist gerade da drin.
So muss man sich das, glaube ich, vorstellen.
Das sind, glaube ich, nicht die ganze Anzahl von Leuten, die man hat.
Ja, ich glaube, es gibt Leute, die das anders konsumieren.
Also ich habe schon wieder Leute, die wirklich einen grossen Teil mitbekommen, die dann wahrscheinlich auch einfach dein Twitter-Profil alle zwei Wochen mal aufrufen und gucken, was du so machst. Weil sie dich interessieren, mache ich ja auch so bei Comedians, die ich gut finde, dass ich die halt unabhängig von meinem Feed halt einfach ab und zu aussuche. Aber es gibt halt Leute, die das wahrscheinlich unterschiedlich sehen. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass ein Grossteil von Humor, also gerade auch in der Stand-Up-Szene oder Cover-Szene oder so ein Kram, auch einfach auf Bestätigung basiert, dass das einfach die grundsätzliche Essenz ist, dieses, ich sage was, wovon ich weiss, dass Leute es genauso sehen und kriegt damit Applaus einfach. Ich will jetzt nicht wieder auf Luke Mockisch rum bashen, aber erinnert ihr euch noch? Das ist einfach nur ein Beispiel dafür. Das ist genau der Impuls, auf den man halt rumreitet. Ja, genau so ist es. Das ist genau dieser, an dem man appelliert, wo man nicht mehr genau weiß, das
sehen die jetzt genauso, sondern das ist ja noch
der viel einfachere Impuls, das haben die mal
genauso erlebt, das ist einfach klar, weil das ein Generationending
ist, das ist ja die viel
einfache Herangehensweise noch. Ja, und vor allem, ich finde, der
Impuls zu applaudieren liegt nicht
darin, dass man selber gut findet, sondern
dass man erwartet, dass man gut gefunden
wird, wenn man jetzt applaudiert. Also
sozusagen, dass wenn er sagt, ey, erinnert euch noch an die Turtles, dann möchte man unbedingt zeigen, dass man sich auch noch an die Turtles kennt, dass man zu der Gruppe der Nineties Kids gehört und muss deswegen klatschen. Vor dem Rechner zu Hause hätte man überhaupt keine Gefühle wahrscheinlich, außer als Nostalgie oder halt sowas in der Richtung, aber man möchte durch dieses Klatschen oder Faven oder Liken oder Sterne geben auch unbedingt zeigen, dass man dazugehört. Das heißt, es ist gar nicht so wichtig, dass... Also glaubst du, man lacht auch manchmal, weil man will, dass andere Leute sehen, dass man lacht? Ja, klar, natürlich. Aber Lachen ist doch eigentlich so ein Reiz, den man hat. Glaubst du, dass diese Reize auch nur aus dem Willen entstehen, Anerkennung zu bekommen? Naja, es gibt ja verschiedene Arten von Lachen. Es gibt einmal das Lachen, das man nicht verhindern kann, wo man auch teilweise über Sachen lacht, über die man nicht lachen darf, einfach weil der Gag so gut ist, sondern so, oh ha ha, hätte man darüber wirklich lachen dürfen, aber es war halt einfach gut. Und dann gibt es natürlich das soziale Lachen, was wahrscheinlich 99,9 Prozent aller Lachen ist, dass man einfach zur Bestätigung lacht und einfach, ja, ich gehöre dazu, ich habe es verstanden, ich lache auch über viele Gags, die ich nicht lustig finde in sozialen Situationen, einfach um irgendwie dazuzugehören, einfach damit es nicht awkward wird und einfach, weil es halt irgendwie einfach eine andere Art der Kommunikation ist. Kann man das üben? Kann man das üben? Ich habe das Gefühl, immer wenn ich lache und es nicht so meine, sieht man mir das total an, habe ich mir das Gefühl. Ja, Leute, die dich kennen, merken mir das auch an. Also ich glaube, ich würde merken, wenn du falsch lachst, aber wenn die Leute dich nicht gut kennen, und in den Situationen macht man es ja meistens, man lacht ja eher falsch, wenn jemanden nicht gut kennt, und je mehr man ihn dann kennt, desto ehrlicher lacht man. Ich glaube, dann kann man es relativ einfach überspielen, tatsächlich. Okay, cool. Ja, dankeschön für diese Antwort. Du bist auch der, der solche Antworten einfach mal geben kann und gar nicht mal in Frage stellt. Also, ja, weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, ich würde mal sagen, dass es so und so einfach die Antwort gibt. Das finde ich gut, so eine Grenzwissenschaft, die wir uns gerade irgendwie annähern, weißt du die Antworten und gibt sie
auch so genau so wieder. Ja, dankeschön. Können wir
über meinem Humorkongress, können wir drüber reden.
Über echtes und falsches Land. Ja, gerne.
Können wir gerne machen.
Also, Sterne verteilen mit Bedarf.
Mein grüner Tee, Zitrone, Tee ist jetzt
leer, also ab jetzt ist es vorbei.
Auf uns alleine gestellt, ja.
Mein Chai-Tee ist auch tatsächlich auch schon leer.
Tatsächlich. Wir bleiben ja bei unseren Tees, also ich finde, ich würde gerne gerne mal einen Tee von dir haben vielleicht. Wir sollten das mal nächste Woche tauschen. Du, ich habe echt tatsächlich ganz viele neue Teesorten bekommen. Ich habe jetzt mittlerweile wirklich wahnsinnig viele und bin gut dabei. Ich habe mir tatsächlich auch einfach mal aus Scheiss heraus Tonic Water, kennst du ja, ne? Ja. Und da habe ich mir auch ganz viele verschiedene Sorten bestellt, einfach um das beste Tonic Water der Welt rauszufinden. Ich habe es auch gefunden, ich habe jetzt die Flasche gerade nicht hier, aber falls euch interessiert, was das beste Tonic Water der Welt ist. Aber dann bestellst du das dann? Im Internet bestellst du dann Wasser? Ja, tatsächlich, auf Amazon gab es so ein Probierpaket, tatsächlich so irgendwie 10 0,2, 0,3 Liter Flaschen von verschiedenen Tonic Waters für genau das Ziel. weil das ist ja wahrscheinlich für irgendwie Cocktail-Fanatiker, die ja den perfekten Gin-Tonic sich mixen wollen und einfach mal zehn ausprobieren und den dann immer kaufen. Und so habe ich es auch gemacht. Da muss man tatsächlich mal gucken, auf Amazon gibt es echt abgefahrene Sachen. Gerade im Lebensmittelbereich kann man da echt viel machen, also auch da eine Empfehlung. Der Lebensmittelbereich ist, glaube ich, auch relativ noch klein im Internet, weil man halt immer daran gegangen ist, ja gut, man kann sich, man kann Lebensmittel nicht so gut verschicken und so, aber es ist ja mittlerweile alles anders. Jetzt, wo es Prime gibt und man den nächsten Tag verschickt. Ich habe gestern viel auf Bahnhöfen rumgehangen, habt ihr vielleicht schon mitbekommen. Und auf Bahnhöfen gibt es ja immer diese Magazinläden, die ja tatsächlich richtig geil sind eigentlich. Also das ist ja ein Phänomen, das es natürlich immer weniger gibt. Und ich habe auch irgendwie eine Zeitung abonniert und ein Magazin, aber halt auf dem E-Book-Reader, das heißt, ich muss nie wieder in so einen Laden gehen, aber wenn man mal Zeit hat, gehe ich einfach mal gerne in so einen
Magazinladen und blätter einfach mal durch, weil es ja unglaublich viele Magazine gibt, das ist ja
unfassbar, für jeden Scheiss und ich habe mal so ein Grillmagazin gelesen und da ist auch auf
jeder zweiten Seite Werbung für Bestell dein Fleisch im Internet und so und das ist halt so
eine Hardcore-Gourmet-Grill und superperfekt und auf einen Grad genau, wie stelle ich meinen Grill genau ein. Aber auch die scheinen irgendwie halbwegs zu unterstützen, dass man sich, oder halt die Zielgruppe scheint es auch anzunehmen, dass man sich Fleisch im Internet bestellt. Also die Zeit, wo man frische Sachen nur um die Ecke bekommen hat, ist auch vorbei. Ist auch vorbei. Ja, wobei der Lade um die Ecke, da bekommt es ja auch geliefert. Ja, eben klar. Also die kommen das ja auch nicht irgendwie, fällt auch nicht, plötzlich kommt es da aus dem Boden oder so. Da kommt dann die Kuh vorbei, ja. Da kann man dazwischen gehen. Aber was ich an diesen Zeitriftenläden immer am interessantesten finde, ist, wie viele Zeitungen doch sehr ähnlich sind. Also die genügend Bild der Frau. Frau, die Frau im Bild, Bild der Frau, Frau in der Welt, Frau in der Küche. Ja, und auch vom Format, ne? Also wenn du es vergleichst, welche Leute da auf dem Cover sind und wie die Farben sind. Es ist immer das Gleiche. Die Überschriften sind nur ein bisschen geändert, es ist halt mal, das Wording ist ein bisschen anders, aber die Bilder sind exakt die gleichen, die Logos sind exakt die gleichen, mit der gleichen Schriftart, in dem gleichen Eck, in dem gleichen Format, die Themen sind exakt die gleichen und es sind immer andere Redakteure, wo ich mich auch frage, was rechtfertigt denn jetzt deren Job nochmal? Ja, und vor allem auch die Themenaufteilung ist auch ähnlich. Also es gibt immer an der Seite, an der gleichen Stelle ist nochmal ein Sexthema in der Frauenzeitschrift, wirklich immer auf der linken Seite, auf der zweiten. Auf das gleiche, aber in welche Richtung? Ähnlich und dann immer einfach nochmal irgendwie, so nimmst du zehn Kilo in einer Woche ab. Und zweites Thema, liebe dich so wie du bist. Es ist immer dieser essentielle Widerspruch jeder Frauenzeitschrift, ist auch einfach genauso auf jedem Cover, auf jedem dieser Cover. Das ist einfach unglaublich. Das ist echt krass. Aber tatsächlich diese Spezialthemen finde ich immer so krass. Ich habe immer ein Schülerpraktikum gemacht im Deutschen Museum, in diesem großen Museum in München. Und musste da auch tatsächlich irgendwie inhaltlich arbeiten und Sachen Vorträge assistieren und sowas. Vorträge halten. Oder Humor. Als Praktikant, ja. Und die haben eine riesige Bibliothek und in der konnte ich mich frei bewegen. Und das Geile ist, die haben aus irgendeinem Grund, also die haben eine wahnsinnig grosse... Das klingt so, als ob sie so eine Leine wäre, plötzlich mit einem Zwinger. Es war tatsächlich sehr geil. Von A bis G kann er gehen. Ja, das war tatsächlich sehr gut. Und die haben auch einen Magazinteil in der Bibliothek, ja, also wahnsinnig, die auch jede Woche gewechselt wird, mit unendlich vielen Magazinen. Also wirklich, stell dir die grösste Bibliothek, die du dir vorstellen kannst, vor und ersetzt einfach Bücher durch Magazine, wirklich reihenweise und du stehst einfach vor und denkst dir what? Und die haben alles, jedes Magazin der Welt. Und es gibt allein, ich glaube, ich habe nachgezählt, es gab zu dem Zeitpunkt zumindest sieben Magazine nur über Maschinengewehre. Nicht über Waffen, sondern über Maschinengewehre. Also ihr erinnert euch, das sind diese Dinger, die von zwei Mann benutzt werden, wo sie auf so einem Stativ stehen, wo man irgendwie 30 Leute in der Sekunde töten kann. Die Teile gibt sieben fucking Magazine, wo man sich auch denkt, wer hat sowas? Hat Maschinengeengewehr, dass man wirklich auch wöchentlich sagt, was schreiben die denn jede Woche da rein? Das ist unfassbar, das ist echt unglaublich. Das ist eine gute Frage. Was schreibt man denn jede Woche rein? Ja, und vor allem, sie schreiben auch von einem ab. Waffen sind ja auch Dinge, die sich jetzt nicht so oft revolutionieren oder so. Vor allem eine Waffenart, die wird ja nicht jede Woche irgendwelche bahnbrechende Neuerungen da haben oder so. Und irgendwann, so nach zehn Aufgaben hat man erklärt, wie die gereinigt wird, man erklärt, wo es die gibt, man erklärt, was man machen kann, schießen halt. Ja, man erklärt, wo es die gibt und erklärt dann auch man, dass man sie in Deutschland einfach nicht besitzen kann. Es wäre geil, wenn auf dem Cover steht, wie man diese Waffe benutzt, wie man die neue AK-30 benutzt. Sehen auf Seite 13, man stellt die Seite 13 auf und steht einfach nur ganz gross, ja, schießen, einfach schießen, man muss einfach draufdrücken. Ja, oder wir leben in Deutschland, man kriegt sie nicht, ja, forget it, vergiss es einfach. Oder auch diese ganze... Sehr grosse Seiten, wo sehr gross draufsteht, ja, man bekommt sie einfach nicht, einfach schießen oder einfach abdrücken, das sind einfach so sehr grosse Seiten, wo sehr gross ein Wort draufsteht. Wir nehmen mal an, Abzug, aber da wir es selber nicht bekommen haben, keine Ahnung. Aber es ist natürlich so, und dann gibt es auch irgendwie so ganz viele Fischermagazine. Und dann gibt es auch ein Magazin nur für Karpfen. Karpfenmagazin. Dann gibt es auch Karpf, Karpf, Karpf, Karpf, ist die Einzahl von Karpfen, oder? Karpf. Ein Karpf. Karpf, ja genau. Und dann gibt es auch Karpf des Monats. Ja, die krö Monat neun Karpfen, einfach als Karpfen des Monats. Und sich auch fragt, wie viele Monat... Leider gibt es nur elf Karpfenarten, was ein bisschen... Ja genau, wo der Chefredakteur auch sagt, okay, elf Karpfen, ein Karpfen die Woche, das heißt, wir gehen in drei Monaten Konkurs, alles klar, bis dann, Leute, haut rein, gebt nochmal alles. Also so eine Idee, die offensichtlich nicht funktioniert. So eine Billiardkugel des Monats. Aber so eine Karpfenzeitschrift kann ich mir auch sehr gut vorstellen, wie das in der Redaktion abgeht. Irgendwie, ja, Hans, wie glaubst du mit dem neuen Karpfenporträt über den Blaukarpfen? Einfach so ganz komische Gespräche, die man auch irgendwie in der Küche führt oder so. Aber wie viele Leute arbeiten daran? Was wollen die denn recherchieren die ganze Zeit? Ich meine, irgendwann hat man doch auch alles aufgedeckt im Karpfenbereich. Ja, vor allem, es ist ja nicht irgendwie so ein Biologie-Magazin, wo man jetzt sagt, irgendwie wie pflanzen die sich fort, wie sind die aufgebaut, wie sieht die DNA aus, das ist ja wahrscheinlich ein riesiges Thema, sondern es sind halt so Hobby, Hobby-Karpfen, einfach so der perfekte Teich oder wie angle ich den Karpfen, das sind ja so seichte Themen, also scheinbar, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht gibt es ja Karpfen-Experten unter euch, also scheinbar seichte Themen, wo man sich mal fragt, kann man da in die Tiefe gehen, das ist unglaublich. Aber ich meine, ich habe jahrelang Magazine über Warhammer und Warhammer 40k gelesen, über kleine Plastikfiguren, die man auf einem Tisch irgendwie hin und her geht. Naja, aber das ist ja so eine Welt, das ist ja so eine Welt, die man da auch macht. Ja, klar, aber es ist auch trotzdem... Aber Karpfen, Karpfen, Fische ist eine Welt für sich, aber Karpfen, also irgendwie ist ja doch, das ist doch irgendwann vorbei, es gibt ja keine Kontroversen im Karpfenbereich, oder? Ja. Oder hast du dann immer, das weiß ich nicht. Ich habe in meinem Kaislander gearbeitet tatsächlich und mein Vorgesetzter war Meeres, der hat Tiermedizin studiert und hat sich auf Fische spezialisiert. Und er hat gesagt so, ja, hallo, mein Name ist Christian, ich bin Tiermediziner, ich mag Fische sowohl im Aquarium als auch auf dem Teller. Und das war teller und das war so sein pitch und ich so okay schön dich kennenzulernen ich fand es einen geilen satz ich mag fische sowohl im aquarium als auch auf dem teller so das ist so geil bei welchem anderen hobby kann man das so sagen einfach ich mag es wenn sie leben ich mag es aber auch wenn sie tot sind so es sind beide Seiten, ich finde die immer gut. Was kann man das denn sagen? Ja, ich bin Diplompsychologin, ich arbeite gern mit Menschen, lebend sowie tot. Genau, aber auf dem Teller. Aber auch auf dem Teller. Das ist so grossartig einfach, das war auch ein krasser Typ, einfach, weil irgendwann hatte ich, ich hatte es nicht so ganz auf dem Schirm, dass der Tiermediziner ist irgendwie und wir mussten da immer so Zeitungen durchgehen, weil wir hatten so Kontaktanzeigen in Zeitungen, mussten dann immer kontrollieren, ob die auch wirklich abgedruckt wurden und mussten, es war eine Scheissarbeit. Und hatten dann so einen Stapel Zeitungen, mussten die immer durchgehen und dann mussten die so durchblättern. Und dann war immer so, ja, Fisch gefangen in der Uckermark, das waren so Lokalzeitungen. Und dann immer so, hier, schau dir mal den Fisch an, von wegen grosser Wels, da habe ich schon größere gesehen.
Das ist auch so Gesprächsanfänge, wo man nicht genau weiß, soll ich jetzt antworten, alles, was ich jetzt sage, wird dir nicht weiterhelfen in deinem Leben. Vor allem, ich wusste nicht, dass der Tiermediziner ist, ich dachte, das wäre einfach ein random Dude, der einfach immer bei jedem Fischthema irgendwie so ein, ja, guck dir mal an, der ist ja nur so groß. Aber das ist auch so ein Thema für Fischleute, dass sie immer auf die Grösse gehen.
Also das ist ja unglaublich. Das ist ja so ein Klischee, dass Fischer immer damit angeben, wie gross die Fische sie gefangen haben. Aber das ist wirklich so, zumindest bei dem Typen, der einfach gesagt hat, ja, ich habe schon mal einen gefangen, der war so gross. Und ich so, ich habe nicht den Hauch einer Referenz, ob das gross oder klein. Und irgendwann musste ich ihn auch mal anrufen, weil da gab es irgendwie einen Notfall im Callcenter und irgendwas ist kaputt gegangen, und du musst ihn anrufen. Notfall im Callcenter, was ist ein Notfall im Callcenter? Das Telefon hat gebrannt, ja. Ja, was zur Hölle? Da ist irgendwie unser Server abgestürzt und ganz viele Leute haben sich angerufen und haben sich beschwert. Das war echt ein geiler Abend, ich hatte Schicht, war echt cool. Und dann habe ich ihn angerufen und dann ist da eine Frau drein gegangen und dann er und ja, tut mir leid, ich habe das Telefon nicht klingeln hören, ich war unten bei meinen Fischen.
Das war auch so ein
okay, cool, also unten hat er
wahrscheinlich seinen ganzen Keller voller Fische,
so ein eigenes Sea-World, ich wollte gar nicht nachfragen,
so, oder hast du ein Restaurant oder was?
Sein Keller ist, glaube ich, ein Riesen-Aquarium,
wo er dann einfach so reintauchen kann,
wo er mit seinen eigenen Fischen tauchen kann.
Das war echt ein weh der Typ, ey.
Das war echt strange.
Der hat auch immer aus dem Fenster gebrüllt, das war immer gut. Wir haben irgendwie, das war auch so geil, zum Thema Aufregen. Passt perfekt, ne? Schau mich mal nicht so dumm an. Passt perfekt zum Thema Aufregen. Und zwar war unser Kurs in der Büro relativ neben so einer Feuerwehr Stelle, wo dann halt die Feuerwehr immer ausgerückt ist. Und das heißt, da war relativ oft Sirenen, weil da auch irgendwie Krankenwägen ständig vorbeigefahren sind. Und halt in München, da haben die anscheinend auch viel zu tun. Das heißt, wir hatten pro Tag halt immer irgendwelche Einsätze mit lauten Sirenen. Und immer wenn die Sirenen gingen, dann hat der aus dem Feld, der gewollt, mach die Sirenen aus, seid leise! Wo ich mir denke, da liegt ein Typ gerade halbtot im fucking Krankenwagen, hoch ausgebildete Leute stehen um ihn rum, versuchen ihn am Leben zu halten, und so ein scheiß Depp im dritten Stock respektiert nicht, dass man dafür jetzt mal eine Sirene braucht, oder was? Wo ich mir auch dachte, wie kannst du dir denn darüber aufregen, dass Not-Einsatzkräfte die Sirene haben? Ja, vor allem auch nicht irgendwer, der irgendwie Ruhe braucht oder so, sondern jemand, der im fucking Callcenter arbeitet, wo man checken muss, welche Anzeigenzeitungen sind in so einem Crap. Wie kann man so egoistisch sein, dass man nicht mal Leuten, die in Not sind, zugesteht, dass es jetzt halt laut ist? Und es ist ja nicht mal ein Wohngebiet, da sind halt Büros, mein Gott, fuck it. Aber Leute regen sich halt einfach gerne auf, ne? Das stimmt. Ich reg mich auch gerne auf. Leute regen sich auch sehr gerne, wenn ich jetzt in den nächsten Tagen aufgefallen habe, über Wärme auf. Also die Temperatur ist ja generell nie richtig. Es gibt nur so ein paar Gradzahlen, wo man sagt, gut, Menschen sind gerade zufrieden.
Menschen sind gerade mit der Temperatur zufrieden. Was ist das? Was ist das mit Gradzahl? 24, 25? So tolerant bin ich nicht. Ich akzeptiere, dass wenn jemand sagt, ich bin Wintermensch oder ich bin Sommermensch, dann erwarte ich aber auch fucking, dass du den gesamten Winter unglücklich und den gesamten Sommer glücklich bist oder andersrum. Du kannst nicht sagen im Winter, ich bin eher der Sommermensch, mir ist zu kalt,
und im Sommer dann sagen, oh, es ist zu heiß.
Das geht nicht, Leute, das ist echt fucking cool, das ist ein scheiß Stil.
Ich bin eher ein Wintertyp, das heißt, im Sommer bin ich durchschnittlich nicht so gut drauf wie im Winter,
weil ich es halt eher kalt mag.
Okay, alles klar, ich kann jetzt aber nicht im Winter sagen, es ist zu kalt, Leute.
Wir können jetzt hier die ganzen Stellen reinschneiden, wo ich im Podcast schon gesagt habe, dass es zu kalt ist, was auch immer.
Ist mir scheißegal, aber das könnt ihr nicht machen, Leute, so funktioniert das einfach nicht.
Wenn ihr sagt, ich muss sagen, es ist zu kalt, Leute. Wir können jetzt hier die ganzen Stellen reinschneiden, wo ich im Podcast schon gesagt habe, dass es zu kalt ist, was auch immer.
Ist mir scheißegal, aber das könnt ihr nicht machen, Leute.
So funktioniert das einfach nicht. Wenn ihr sagt, ich bin nur zu gewissen Zeiten glücklich, dann seid auch in den
Zeiten fucking glücklich und nicht da auch noch
fucking schlecht drauf.
Mein Gott, da kann ich nicht immer schlecht
drauf sein, ey. Puh. Reist euch mal zusammen.
Du bist ein Sommermensch, wie man gerade merkt.
Du bist ein Sommermensch.
Jetzt moderiert die Öl. Ja, mach an, jetzt komm. Ja, ich fand die Überleitung jetzt gar nicht so schlecht, relativ gelungen. Und zwar haben wir unsere tolle Rubrik wieder ans Land gezogen, die nämlich heisst Topical Island. Topical Island. Die Rubrik, in der wir uns mit aktuellen Themen beschäftigen und so ironisch, karkastisch, humorvoll versuchen aufzuklären. Das ist Topical Island und unser Thema der Woche lautet Wärme, die Hitze. Es ist Sommer. Das bedeutet, dass die Erdkugel in dem Umfang geneigt ist, dass nun die Bereiche, in denen Sie und ich leben, näher an der Sonne sind, als die Bereiche, in denen wir nicht leben. Das bedeutet, dass wir mehr von der Sonneneinstellung zu spüren bekommen, die Temperatur steigt. Das hat was zur Folge? Und was kann man, unsere Frage ist, was kann man dagegen tun? Wie können wir uns am besten gegen die Wärme wappnen? Was machen wir? Was sollen wir tun? Wo sollen wir hingehen? Was sollen wir für Hilfsmittel mitnehmen,
damit es uns wieder besser geht?
Will den Unmenschen nicht auf den Sack gehen?
Mit unseren ewigen Gerungeplärre, dass es zu warm ist.
Und dafür haben wir jetzt, jeder von uns,
Florentin hat drei, ich habe drei Ideen mitgebracht,
die euch, liebe Podcast-Ufohörer,
exklusiv dabei helfen sollen,
ein glücklicherer Mensch zu sein.
Und Florentin, bei dir Nummer drei, was ist es bei dir?
Und mein erster Tipp ist, gehe niemals bei Rot über die Ampel, auch wenn niemand hinschaut. Kleine Regel für den Sommer. Okay. Mein Tipp ist, zu Hause bleiben. Einfach zu Hause bleiben, es vielleicht ein bisschen kälter, die Heizung kalt drehen, dass sie kühlen, so dass sie kühlen vielleicht. Ja, da müssen wir noch mal ganz kurz überreden. Ich weiß nicht. Da ist ja so eine Schneeflocke immer bei den Anzeigen von Heizungen, ne? Ja, genau. Das meinte ich ja gerade damit. Also, wie gesagt, Heizungen haben, ja, Entschuldigung, wenn du meine Pointen reingrächt. Lässt mich hier mit einer Halberektion stehen, erst teaserst rum, dann will ich den Gag machen, und dann kommst du und grätsch zu... Ja, warum habe ich das denn auf Platz drei aufgeschrieben als mein Gag vielleicht?
Ja, das ist scheiße, ich habe keinen Bock auf die
Rubri, das kotzt mich an.
Ne, ich mutiere ab. Das war
Topical Island zum Thema Hitze.
Topical Island,
Topical Island, Topical
Island, da kommt wahrscheinlich noch
Musik. Und dann, aber an Heizungen ist ja auch immer
dann dieses, dieser Frost, das Frost-Symbol. Ja. Und wenn man da hreht, ist es trotzdem, es wird halt nie kalt. Das ist halt das Ding von Heizungen. Ja, aber man muss schon sagen, Heizungen sind, wenn sie... Man könnte einfach einen Mittelfinger da rauf machen, statt dass der Schneeflugge ein grosser Mittelfinger. Aber ich finde, wenn Heizungen nicht heiß sind, dann sind sie schon sehr kalt, tatsächlich. Muss man schon mal sagen, finde ich. Ja, dann finde ich es so kalt, dass man zu Hause bleiben soll, die Heizungen auch sehr kalt dre. Und dann kann man sich so ein kleines Lagerfeuer machen und dann vielleicht den Kühlschrank nochmal länger offen stehen lassen.
Das ist ja tatsächlich so, das hat das amerikanische Militär im Irak gemacht, als sie gesagt haben, oh, hier ist ja echt warm und die Soldaten wollten kühles Bier haben.
Also was haben sie gemacht? Sie haben Bier vergraben und da, wo sie das Bier vergraben haben, haben sie so eine Pfütze Benzin gemacht, haben
das Benzin angezündet und dadurch
wurde das Bier kalt.
Und man weiss bis heute nicht genau warum, aber es funktioniert
tatsächlich. Es funktioniert auch wirklich tatsächlich.
Es ist kein Witz, es funktioniert wirklich.
Ja, weil es da im fucking Iran
einfach wärmer ist als in Flammen.
Weil es trotzdem außenrum
noch wesentlich heißer
ist als in Flammen. Aber es ist ja auch so, ich habe eben gesagt, wenn wir einfach den Kühlschrank aufmachen, es ist immer ein Gag, ein humoristischer Gag, aber in Wirklichkeit, das hat bei irgendwer getestet, wenn man den Kühlschrank aufmacht, wird die Wohnung nicht kühler, sondern wärmer. Ja, aber das ist ja irgendwo klar, oder? Ja, es ist doch irgendwo klar, ich wollte nur mal ein bisschen Wissen mitgeben. Mein Gott, dann Nummer zwei. Oh, ich habe tatsächlich große Probleme mit meinen Kopfhörern, fällt mir gerade ein. Und ich habe mich letztens wieder gefühlt wie der letzte Trottel, weil gerade denkt man, okay, Physik ist immer so ein Thema, wo man sich schnell mal irgendwie ins Kornfeld setzt und sagt, oh, dumm. So wie man immer denkt, dass schwere Dinge schneller fallen als leichte Dinge, ist nicht der Fall. Ist aber so ein Klassisches, wo man auf Partys Leute irgendwie dann sagen kann, ah, du bist ein Trottel, du hast nicht aufgepasst in der neunten Klasse, und dann sagt der andere, ja gut, du hast so gut wie gar keine Freunde und... Schwere Dinge fallen wesentlich schneller. Nein, tun sie nicht. Im Vakuum nicht. Auch so nicht. Sehr geil, sehr guter Fluchtversuch noch in der letzten Sekunde. Doch, es ist wirklich egal. Ich bin mir sicher, dass wenn du etwas sehr Leichtes runterschmeißt aus dem Fenster, wenn du es einen Fehler runterschmeißt oder ein Pasten Bier aus dem Fenster... Es kommt nur auf den Luftwiderstand an. Wenn du eine Bowlingkugel hast und eine Kugel, die genauso groß ist, aber leichter, dann fällt die Bowlingkugel genauso schnell wie die andere Kugel. Ja, und im Vakuum fällt das
gleichzeitig, teckt das nachher auch.
Nein, im Vakuum gibt es keinen Luftwiderstand,
das heißt, im Vakuum fällt die Feder genauso schnell
wie ein Hammer. Das habe ich doch gesagt, das habe ich doch gerade
gesagt, Florentin. Ja, aber deine Verbindungsschwierigkeiten
sind bestehend, deswegen habe ich es nicht gehört.
Auf jeden Fall, mein Kopfhörer ist kaputt gegangen, ich habe ja
immer so In-Ear-Kopfhörer und mir
passiert immer dasselbe, und zwar es geht immer
eine Seite kaputt, immer die rechte
Seite geht irgendwann kaputt, so nachdem ich die sechs
Monate lang benutzt habe, ist immer die Seite kaputt gegangen.
Das heisst, ich habe jetzt zwei Paare
oder halt zwei
Kopfhörer,
zwei Paare, also
vier, also zwei
zwei Paar
Kopfhörer, wo ich insgesamt Feelgood-Bahn machtahn macht es hier auch einfach völlig bescheuert im Kopf. Insgesamt ein Paar Kopfhörer, also ein Paar ... So, ich mache schon mal meine Nummer zwei. Meine Nummer zwei gegen die Hitze wäre einen sehr grossen Eiswürfel, den man immer mitnimmt. So einen sehr, sehr, sehr grossen Eiswürfel, den man sich macht. So einen ganz, ganz grossen Eiswürfel, den kannst du überall mit hinnehmen, in der Tasche und so.
Und dann hast du quasi den ganzen Tag ein bisschen was Kälte mit dir. Also du streichst quasi das, was du brauchst, immer mit dir rum, Kälte. Und dann kannst du dich umarmen und es ist immer kalt und so. Das ist mein Tipp persönlicher. Habe ich so noch nirgendwo gesehen. Das heisst, ich habe jetzt zwei Kopfhörer mit jeweils einem davon Kopfhörer-Defekt.
Jetzt habe ich mir gedacht, ich bin ja nicht dumm. Das ist so, wenn du zwei Schuhe verlierst, dann ziehst du einfach die beiden übrig gebliebenen zusammen an, weil dann hast du ja wieder zwei Schuhe. Und so dachte ich mir, mache ich das auch. Und zwar in der Fachsprache nennt man das eine Peitsche, Ein Audioverteiler, das heisst so ein Augskabel, wo man einen Eingang und zwei Ausgänge hat. Und das heisst, ich habe in mein iPhone-Ding reingesteckt und dann in diesen Verteiler zwei Kopfhörer und hört es aus den jeweils Kopfhörern ein. Und ich habe damit wirklich das Haus verlassen mit der Sonnenbrille auch so, yeah, okay, ladies, kommt vorbei, ich bin der fucking krasseste. Und in dem Moment, in dem ich draußen war, dachte ich mir, du bist der grösste Vollidiot der Welt, du bist wirklich so dumm, wie kannst, wie hast du es überhaupt geschafft, so lange zu überleben, du bist der grösste Trottel, das sieht so dumm aus, das sieht so bescheuert aus. Ja, aber was ich mich frage, beide Male sind rechts, der Kopfhörer, kaputt gegangen, oder? Ja. Also du hast zwei Linke, ja, das heisst, du hörst bei manchen Gielen, inwiefern Stereo ist für dich auch so, also du kannst keine Lieder hören, die irgendwel du hast zwei Linke. Ja, das weiss ich echt.
Du weißt bei manchen Gielen, denn trotzdem Stereo ist für dich
auch so auch mal. Also du kannst keine Lieder hören,
die irgendwelche Effekte haben.
Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt, ob diese Palche das irgendwie dann umkonfiguriert,
aber das ist ein guter Punkt, darauf muss ich echt achten.
Aber tatsächlich sind Stereo-Lieder sowieso
der grösste Schwachsinn der Welt.
Ich finde auch, unser Podcast sollte
rechts, Florentin, links, Stefan haben, oder umgekehrt.
Das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen, oder?
Also als ich die Folge noch geschnitten habe, habe ich das so gemacht? Dann glaube ich das so gemacht. Ach so. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es immer noch so machst, jetzt schneidest ja du, aber ich habe immer so gemacht, dass einer... Ich schneide immer rechts Stefan, links Stefan, Florentin, halb auf beidem. Ja, vielleicht schneide ich Florentin auch aus. Vielleicht bin es nur ich, der sich mit mir alleine unterhält. Mal sehen. Ja, mal gucken. Ich weiß nicht, wie wir es machen. Mal gucken. Mal gucken mal. War das eine geile Kopfhörergeschichte? Ja. Ich habe auch schon Topical Island abmodelliert. Ich mache da nicht mehr mit. Die Rubrik können wir begraben. Ich habe jetzt, ich habe wissenschaftlich jetzt mal, bin ich zu Tage gegangen und habe gedacht, gut, du brauchst einen Platz eins, der muss reinhauen. Du hast den grandiosen Tipp mit dem grossen Eiswürfel, du hast den grandiosen Tipp mit dem Zuhause bleiben. Ich finde, ich brauche jetzt etwas, wo man am Ende nochmal was mitgeben kann, ähnlich wie die Bahn, am Ende nochmal so ein kleiner Schmankerl hinten reinhaut, wo man sagt, hey, das ist ein gutes Produkt, das ist eine gute Firma, diesen Podcast höre ich gerne, das ist was Gutes, da habe ich mir was für Leben. Ja, bei Minute 56 kriege ich nochmal einen Tipp, wie mir nicht heiß wird. Den Leuten ist es jetzt schon heiß. Die Leute schwitzen wie Sau. Wissenschaftlich gesehen, wissenschaftlich gesehen zieht Wärme ja immer nach oben. So, also das ist mein Tipp, einfach auf den Boden legen. Einfach auf den Boden legen. Oder klein sein. Euch passiert gar nichts. Sehr, sehr klein sein
oder auf den Boden legen.
Das ist mein Tipp. Und ich denke,
ich habe nicht zu viel versprochen, das war wissenschaftlich
fundiert ein guter Tipp.
Gegenargument! Jeden zu Hause.
Das Topical Island Gegenargument!
Das Topical Island
Gegenargument!
Ja, ist es denn nicht so? Du hast zwar generell
recht, wenn man höher geht, wird es kühler, weil die Luft kühler ist.
Ich finde nicht, dass du noch reden darfst in dieser Rubrik, weil du hast die Rubrik schon abmoderiert.
Die Rubrik verabscheut dich gerade.
Entweder du moderierst dich wieder an, redest und moderierst dich wieder ab, oder du lässt es sein.
Ne, dann entscheide ich mich für abmoderiert.
Du kriegst jetzt kein Gegenargument.
Gut, wenn du so mit Kritik umgehst.
Okay.
Nein.
Gut. Nein, die Topical Island ist einfach nur eine sehr eingeschlappte Rubrik, das ist eine sehr sensible Rubrik, die kannst du nicht einfach so wegschieben und dann trotzdem in dir weiter rumrühren, das geht nicht. Ich hatte früher ein Hochbett, ja, und in Hochbetten ist es fucking heiß. Ich hatte zweimal in meinem Leben ein Hochbett, einmal als Kind und einmal in meinem Wohnheim, als ich nach Berlin gezogen wurde, und da war es so fucking heiß in Hochbetett. Und da ist es tatsächlich so, dass man sich denkt, ja, ich schlafe lieber auf meinem Schreibtisch unten als in diesem Hochbett. Weil Wärme nach oben zieht. Das ist echt krass. Krass, aber... Und warum? Topical Island, Topical Island, Topical Island, Topical Island. Ich habe eine Anekdote, in die ich auch gerne einen Gag einbauen würde.
Jetzt ist meine folgende Frage folgende.
Soll ich erst den Gag sagen und dann die Anekdote erzählen?
Soll ich erst die Anekdote erzählen, dann den Gag, oder soll ich den Gag in der Anekdote unterbringen?
Wie soll ich es machen?
Hau raus. Hau einfach alles auf einmal raus am besten.
Okay. Ich wollte letztens Spaghetti kochen und wollte aber nur eine gewisse Grammanzahl Spaghetti kochen, aus einem Grund, der jetzt nicht näher definiert wird. Es geht um ein kulinarisches Experiment. Spaghetti-Ballonese. Und ich habe aber keine Waage. Das kulinische. Ich habe keine Waage. Spaghetti mit Tomatensauce, ja. Ich hatte aber tatsächlich keine Waage. Das heißt, wie macht man es? Ich hatte verschiedene Möglichkeiten zur Auswahl. Erst dachte ich mir, naja, ich kann ja so viel Wasser abfüllen, denn 300 Milliliter Wasser wiegen 300 Gramm. Und ich brauchte genau 300 Gramm. Das heißt, ich habe 300 Milliliter Wasser abgewogen und habe dann so versucht, aus so einem Schneidebrett so eine Waage zu improvisieren, indem ich so einen Kugelschreiber genommen habe, da das Schneidebrett draufgelegt habe, so wie so eine Waage, hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert, weil ich da auch einen Grossteil des Wassers aus Versehen verschildert habe, tatsächlich bei dem Bereich. Dann habe ich mir überlegt, ich mache es anders. Die ungarische Familie unterm Stockwerk da runter ist einfach ertrunken, einfach weil so ein ... Drei Milliliter Wasser, die Treppe runterkam. Und dann dachte ich mir, ich stelle mich auf die Personenwaage, einmal normal und einmal mit Spaghetti in der Hand.
Und dann müsste ja die Differenz eigentlich dem Wert der Spaghetti entsprechen.
Das heißt, ich habe mich gewogen, ja.
Mit Schüssel natürlich, du hast wohl die Schüssel genullt damit.
Genau, ich habe mich genullt sozusagen, mich gewogen, ja, 68 Kilo, wie immer, wunderbar,
habe mich dann nochmal gewogen, mit Spaghetti in der Hand, und ich war leichter. Und ich dachte mir, what? Was ist denn hier, also entweder habe ich grundlegende Züge der Schwerkraft nicht verstanden, oder die Waage funktioniert nicht. Oder Spaghetti sind so leicht, oder die sind irgendwie so Luft drin oder so, dass sie quasi wie Helium-Ballons wirken und dich so leicht abheben lassen. Oder ich glaube, entweder du hast gerade die beste Diät der Welt entdeckt oder irgendwie, weiß ich nicht. Ja, Spaghetti, damit meldet man ab. Ja, ich kann auch den 68 Kilo nicht mehr trauen tatsächlich mittlerweile. Von daher bin ich jetzt irgendwie, meine Diät glaube ich letztendlich. Den würde ich generell nicht so, ich würde den 68 Kilo vielleicht generell nicht so trauen. Weiß nicht. Jetzt kommt der Gag.
Ja. Die Einzahl von Spaghetti nennt man Spaghetto. Ja. Das wäre der Gag. Damit ist das auch abgeschlossen. Mit diesem Gag würde ich sagen, wir machen es wie die Bahn. Tatsächlich machen wir heute anscheinend genau wie die Bahn. Wir gehen, nee, wir machen es gegensätzlich heute mal. Wir gehen mit dem Spaghetto-Gag raus. Da hättest du mich jetzt fast gelobt, aber dann musste der zynische Stefan nochmal unbedingt seine Zynismus-Keule rausholen, weil es mir da nicht gut geht. Familie Tietze ist seit Jahren im Gelontologie-Geschäft tätig. So, ich möchte das nicht mehr von den Leuten hier austragen. Ich würde mich gerne verabschieden. Das war's von uns. Das war's von uns. Von Florentin, Will und Stefan Tietze aus ihrem Podcast-Ufo, aus der Brücke des Podcast-Ufos.
Ihr habt eine Menge Hausaufgaben, Leute. Ja, nur weil es draußen heisst, das heisst nicht, dass ihr hitzefrei habt.
Erstens, ihr geht jetzt mal auf unsere fucking Seite und drückt den Flatter-Button, denn wir wollen nach Basel.
Und wenn wir nicht irgendwie mindestens 120 Euro zusammenkriegen, können wir nicht nach Basel.
Zweitens, ihr geht auf Twitter und folgt uns auf Twitter, ihr folgt uns auf Facebook, ihr schreibt Stefan Tietze meine aufmuntende Nachricht, damit er nicht immer so schlecht drauf sein muss. Basel, Basel, Basel, wir fahren nach Basel. Und ansonsten wünschen wir euch natürlich eine schöne Woche, Mensch, den Sommer genießt mal, geht mal raus, zieht eure Kleidung aus und genießt die Sonne einfach mal draußen. Erlebt mal was, bleibt nicht in der Wohnung, aber bleibt auch draußen auf dem Boden, wo sowohl duchstäblich, weil es ja kälter ist, als auch metaphorisch gesehen auf dem Boden bleiben.
Das war's von uns.
Das war fantastisch. Bis dann.